there is a new dog in town and it's the
first of its kind in the valley Rocky is
live at brewdog Las Vegas for a tour
before its grand opening this weekend hi
Rocky
hey ladies this place is spectacular I
couldn't think of another word do you
have another word to describe brewdog
here in Las Vegas it's awesome it's
awesome it's so great here it's two
stories we've got an outdoor patio too
we'll show you we'll show you that later
on in the show but JB this is your baby
you know tell us just about Brew dog you
guys are the very first carbon negative
brew house here in Vegas yeah so and we
we believe in three key things which is
great beer looking after our people and
looking after our home planet so copper
negative we offset everything that
customers have we offset that and make
sure that we look after the planet and
we we plant our own trees in our forests
in Scotland wow okay so let's talk about
the origin of Brew dog you said Scotland
yeah so we're a Scottish based company
although we now have breweries in Ohio
Brisbane and Australia and in Germany as
well and this one just happens to be the
biggest of brewdog of the brewdog family
so I guess you know it makes sense that
you brought it to the Las Vegas Strip
yeah we were we were desperate to open a
bar in Las Vegas and when we saw this
property with this incredible rooftop up
with 365 degrees of view of the strip we
we just we just loved it and we've spent
the last year and a half building this
place and we're in love with the place
well good job
good job I get to the grand opening this
week and we're going to give you those
details later on in the show let's talk
about the menu because I know the beer
is good but I heard the food is
exquisite as well yeah we we love great
beer and we love pairing it with awesome
food and so here we have what we call
the Flying Scotsman Burger yeah these
are fresh cut fries made in-house oh my
gosh we've got these fries are so good
these are awesome so um this is a
Scottish Burger so again play into our
Scottish Roots as a business and we're
what makes it a Scottish Burger well
it's a beef patty and onion rings and
these are all American but the the most
important ingredient in this burger is
haggis so Scottish haggis
um and yeah so spiced meat and a
traditional traditional national dish
from Scotland and we've put it together
with a Whiskey sauce and so all good I
love it I love a good little culture
here too at brewdog and before we go you
I see Elvis juice I see the Elvis you
know brew and on the wall here says
Elvis pouring daily not performing so
explain that so Elvis is our number one
selling beer across the U.S
um and yeah coming coming to Vegas which
was so famous for Elvis we thought we'd
uh we'd have a bit of fun with anyone
sign and also a champion our
best-selling beer now why is this the
best selling beer what makes a special
besides it being Elvis well it's a first
of all it tastes amazing so it's a
grapefruit infused IPA and like just
like on a summer's day and the nice cold
beer in your hand it just tastes great
okay well I look forward to tasting the
beer on the patio with the amazing view
we'll show you that coming up later on
in the show thanks Davey Oh bring us
back some Elvis juice that sounds
delicious
thank you so much yes all right we're
gonna check